[موسيقى]
بنيامين مور
غاري مور
وسط البنفسج هو إما عقل صيادنا
لعبت بجانبي 3 هل تحب هذه اللعبة البيضاء
مشاركة الروبية orban u shea بالنسبة لها كيف
يمكن أن تحسب غابات الهيروين ذلك بالضبط
هل سقط الدخل غروب الشمس أو كل صنبور ط
وميض الجبال b0 أورسولا أو مرات
ديك وكييف سواء المتسكعون usbu anka الأميال
على المصباح الأمامي من العصا وفي 1 أ نقدم لحم العجل
جميلة شكل sachen قمم بمعنى
وجه جون 2 الغراب الأسود الملقب
فيلم 13 rb well bush 1000 miles
كان إيجور مصابًا بالربو مني حتى أتمكن من ذلك
واضح
[موسيقى]
الكثير الغيتار الكهربائي
سكا
خطاب
حسنا منفردا
أنت
[موسيقى]
يعرض
وإعطاء هذا المكان مروحة ضيقة
[موسيقى]
لو
نحن فقط
[موسيقى]
يسمى الأحمر وحان الوقت
Okyste UAH حتى الدجاج في المنزل سأجيب
قد يتصل مرساة والمشاركة في
أحسب نوع هزلي أي مبلغ بها
بشكل عام ، لا يصدقني الناس بشكل مباشر
على مستوى أنهم لا يتحدثون فقط
أعطت واحدة كما دفعت جميع المستحقة
شكل وهذا نوع من العودة لمن أنت
أنت تعلم أنك تصرخ طلباً للمساعدة والمتابعة
الاضطهاد الذي تضطهده
لنأخذ البنادق
نرى أن يعدوا بواجبهم تجاه أحبائهم
أنت
قصة الأخ وصفة العجائب ط
لقد نسيت أنني خدمت بموجب عقد
حضري معًا لم يمض وقت طويل على ذلك
كتب للتو شيئًا غير مألوف
يتحدثون عن كذا وكذا فهم جميعًا ينقذوني
نعتقد هنا
هذا كل ما لا علاقة له
منشط قد ترك المعاني هي
لوموف
حلو جدا مكتب الأوكرانيين سيم
تقع خلف أوقات فرنسا عبر الأطواق
القلق كان الجميع لطفاء معك
الفرسان بدورهم كل مأوى ضارة
إرادة البلاد قوة أقل وإعادة
ديكو الخ
الجيش غريب السيطرة الفودكا الفنادق
معاش الجيش الروسي
[تصفيق]
التحكم الملائم نعم احتفظ به هكذا أو أنت
استرخِ بشكل أفضل في المنزل
الرقيقة أيسر
شربت البيرة وحزمتك بعد
الكتابة
يوكي من النوع المنحرف
يحب
هنا الهند
أوه يا لزجة أعيش هنا
إنهم هنا تمامًا هنا في الحديقة
[موسيقى]
كان هناك الأوكرانية
إنه ليس آمنًا هناك
كاشف و
مشاركة مدونة
جلوسها
أشاهد اللحظة
في التايغا لايكوس مثل الدبابة
[موسيقى]
ورشة عمل لن تذهب
يبدو أن الباقة
متى
بدأ الروس بالهجوم من الجانب
بارك مباشرة
كان هناك الكثير من المدنيين هنا
هذا
لم يهتموا
أطلقوا النار على كل من رأوه
على المدنيين
مرحبا بكم في الجحيم
[تصفيق]
حتى
ولكن ليس على الكلاب
نحن
نحن لا نختبئ ، نحن لا نتراجع ولا نستسلم
لا شبر واحد من أرضنا الأم
كل كلب من سكان موسكو جاء
في أرضنا هي في أرضنا بيري
العمل على التربة السوداء ، وسوف تذهب بقاياهم
في توابيت الزنك في أحسن الأحوال
[موسيقى]
مع
سوف يجتمعون في الحمام من أجل الجودة
لكن
[موسيقى]
مرافقة رجل 16 شابا
المجندين من بورياتيا الروسية من بورياتيا نعم
سألهم الناس
ماذا فعلت أوكرانيا لك بورياتيا لماذا
لقد أتيت إلى هنا
تحطيم
لم يأمرونا بشيء مثل هذا
تم إعطاء الأمر
خذها هنا تمامًا مثل هذا
دعنا نذهب لأنه كان هناك قياس meina
حوالي 20 جثة فقط
لا أعرف ماذا تسميها
رفع معدل ريما يصل إلى جميع أنحاء الإقليم
وزن نحو 20 جثة مدنيين
من ركب الدراجات وما إلى ذلك
وما شابه
صدمت
شكرًا لك
مع بلدي 7
من
دنيوي
فاز
خيارات على الفور Balda-Balda Khmelnytsky
[موسيقى]
أ
ثم ما زلت بحاجة إلى الوجوه حتى 20
المجد لأوكرانيا ، المجد للأبطال
100d أنت الآن
tse duzhe القداس المقدس
السلاف
السلاف سفياتو روسيف
هنا بالنظر إلى أ
نحن الآن أوكرانيون ، فنحن أوكرانيون في كل شيء
line vchimosya أنا بارد الجليد أعرف أنا
درست ، أدرس إيماننا ، إيماننا
ربما ليس نفس القديم ، ظللت أفكر
أصبحنا أوكرانيين وبسبب حقيقة أننا كنا كذلك
كفاح
[موسيقى]
أنا جاهز للتجلط
هؤلاء الشواذ يضربون مدفعيتنا
مواقفنا
الآن سيكون الجواب ، دعونا نعطيهم العاهرات
على طول الإطار
عالي
المراسي
[موسيقى]
هنا بالجسور والكتيبة
في
لنا أكثر على هذا
إرادة الصبر
[موسيقى]
الزوج المتاعب وحدها هي تستهدف القطة الصغيرة
متكبرون راسينانتا مريح 1 إلى 2 دينار
هذا هو السيارات والكلية أو سهل
[موسيقى]